what we're doing as of the end of next
month is substantially increasing the
support that we're providing for those
who are taking on child care who are in
work and receiving Universal Credit so
that's a 47 increase in the amount that
people can claim so a huge increase
there the second thing we're doing is
one of the things that's present
prevented people taking on child care in
the past has been the fact that they've
having to find the money up front so
we're removing that problem by helping
them with those child care costs so this
is a very major step and of course what
this will lead 2K in time is a greater
participation in the labor force and so
what we want is want more people in work
so we can ease those tight labor markets
those businesses that are really
struggling to find the right people and
child care is absolutely key to that why
haven't you done it before now well
we've done a lot of things that we've
been rolling out in the past including
free child care and of course we have
had support for child care through
Universal Credit but what the last
budget did in the spring was to put a
firm emphasis on labor market
interventions that will boost the size
of the workforce and this is one of the
ones that the office for Budget
responsibility incidentally says will
have the most significant impact so this
will be a major step okay what are you
going to do about people who are
resorting to shoplifting things like
baby food because they literally can't
afford to feed their kids otherwise we
totally recognize that this is a very
difficult time particularly with high
inflation and High Core inflation food
inflation and we're seeing that in other
countries Sweden Portugal Germany for
example are very similar levels of
inflation so what we're doing to answer
your question is as much support as we
can provide to those who need it the
most so through my department cost of
living payments have been going out last
year they're going out this year there's
900 pounds for 8 million people in
low-income households 150 pounds for
those that are disabled 300 pounds with
the winter fuel payment for pensioners
we put up the national living wage by
9.7 okay percent the energy price
guarantee where we've had a windfall tax
on the energy producers to half fuel
bills so those are really important
things that we can do in the face of
pressures that a lot of countries are
now Saturday and yet still people feel
that they have to shoplift baby for me
loads should they be prosecuted if they
shop if maybe from your people well it's
not for me to well it's not feeling
shoplifting is wrong and all theft is is
wrong and I would never justify that of
course it's a down to the individual uh
store that may find itself in that
situation to make those judgments not
for me and for the police
um but what I'm saying is that this
government is absolutely on the side as
I've just identified of those who are
struggling the most to give them as much
support as we can and incidentally the
sport with child care of course will not
just be for those newly going into the
workforce okay it'll be additional
support for those who are already
receiving that offer what do you make of
what the Asda chairman has been saying
he says governments of any complexion
owe us a debt of gratitude and this
recent speculation over the last couple
of days about fixing prices is frankly
rather backward looking okay well so I
think if you look at the idea of fixing
prices or oligopolies or monopolies Etc
that's a matter for the competition and
markets Authority and indeed their
investing skating at the moment unit
pricing what the government well what
what the government is really about and
this is why we've been having
conversations with food producers with
Farmers with uh the supermarkets
themselves is just making sure that the
market is working as efficiently and
effectively as it can do to keep prices
as low as possible but there's no
getting away from the fact that we do
have high inflation now we've come off
the back good looking we've come off the
back of of covid we had to spend 400
billion pounds supporting the economy
then we've got the Warren between Russia
and Ukraine Tennessee
every day and I allowed you to speak
without interruption about Universal
Credit backward looking is what he says
well if if that's referring to looking
at pricing and so the notion of price
capping well we're not I think heading
towards the 1970s and lots of price
controls uh left right and center but I
do think when we have these particular
pressures is responsible of government
to have a dialogue with the supermarkets
and food producers and so on to see what
can collectively be done to try and keep
those price Rises as low as possible and
I don't think that's an unreasonable I'm
sorry are they doing enough supermarkets
well as I say the competition markets
Authority is looking into this whole
issue of unit pricing and will come to
its own conclusion so it's not for me to
prejudge that but as I say we're on the
side of consumers particularly the most
vulnerable with the payments that I've
described earlier and we're also making
sure we're involved in the in those
conversations to try and do whatever we
can to keep prices down now look all the
forecasts are that inflation should be
about half the level at the end of this
year as it has been at the beginning of
this year and that's one of the key
missions that the Prime Minister set and
he's absolutely right and we're right as
a government to do that okay because
that will ultimately take the pressure
off let's wait and see um interest rates
let me ask you about this one because we
had Andrew Labs is that where you are
yeah last week um and as you know she's
involved with the finance committee and
obviously the dining Street very
interested in what they have to say
they're very upset that interest rates
for some people pensioners potentially
who tend to vote Labor uh vote
conservative forgive me
we don't take anything there we are tend
to vote conservative
um they may have some savings and the
interest rates are not being passed on
to uh people who've got perhaps some
money in their savings account to the
extent of 23 billion pounds a year what
should the government do to sort the
banks out so the treasury select
committee has been looking I used to
chair that commission for a period of
three years and uh I know that they're
carrying out a very thorough
investigation of it that's a lot of
notes that they're looking yeah look
looking at their conclusions I think
broadly speaking the Banking and
Financial Services sector is a a
relatively efficient and highly
competitive Marketplace so you would
respect as one particular Bank starts to
change its rates others to follow but it
is sticky and of course government the
business department and Treasury and
others are often involved in discussions
with banks about exactly those kind of
things
well it is a it is a free market and
people of course my advice generally
would be if you feel you're getting a
very poor rate uh with one particular
institution is shopping around and find
one that will apply pay a better rate
and there are those out there now some
of the stickiness well some of the
stickiness comes because there's often
inertia as between the customer and the
bank itself in other words you know do I
want to do it but it's relatively easy
to change and switch accounts um and
it's worth worth shopping around and so
my advice to anybody of whatever age
actually is if there are better deals
out there with similar institutions on a
similar basis then then move your
account yeah let me ask you about the
covert inquiry Before I Let You Go uh
baroness Hallett as you know he's got uh
involved she said if the cabinet
maintains its position that it does not
hold specified materials it must provide
in substitute a witness statement from a
senior civil servant verified by
statement of Truth in other words she
doesn't believe that these documents are
not available to hand over to her both
WhatsApp messages and also the former
prime minister's Diaries should they be
handed over so what the government is
doing here is we've started this inquiry
because we think it's very important
that we get to the bottom of some really
important questions that many many
millions of people want to know the
answers to around the covid pandemic and
our response to it we've provided around
55 000 documents eight witness
statements some corporate witness
statements as well to the inquiry and we
absolutely intend to continue to be
absolutely transparent and candid now
when it comes to this yeah well she's
extended I think baroness Hannah is
extended deadline until tomorrow at four
o'clock it's not really for me to
pre-judge exactly where that is going to
land other than to say that I'm
absolutely certain and confident that
the cabinet office will be engaged in
this in exactly the right kind of way
and in the kind of spirit that I've just
outlined of making sure that we are
absolutely robustly transparent where it
is appropriate to be so and I think
that's an important qualification so
that that inquiry has all the
information that it is right for it to
have